les vieux et la technologie sait pas
encore c'est particulier quoi déjà déjà
quand il en parle quand il parle de
technologie
j'ai l'impression qu'ils font tout leur
possible ils font leur maximum pour se
tromper
oulala je capte mal là où il fit
peut-être redémarrer la pasta box
d'ailleurs un des passe temps des vieux
mais être un article là où il y en a pas
par exemple venu montre moi ton truc sur
l'internet internet pas l'internet
répétez après moi
internet a mais tu sais que moi aussi je
vais sur le facebook juste facebook
c'est fini
mes parents par exemple ils galèrent
mais ils galèrent à un niveau
professionnel quoi s'est il essaye mais
ils font n'importe quoi
ma mère quand elle fait une recherche
sur internet elle fait ça alors
google.com
voilà là au moins t'es sûr d'être sur
google là c'est certain il n'y a pas de
doute tu t'es pas trompé de site et je
crois que ma mère c'est la personne qui
tape le moins vite au monde sur un
clavier sa joie je m'en suis
spécialement rendu compte quand helm a
ajouté sur facebook
what we parce qu'elles pensent que lol
ça veut dire oui sur internet c'est
irrécupérable
on peut plus rapport est le truc que je
déteste le plus c'est quand mes parents
m'appellent pour je les aide en
informatique ils sont tellement mauvais
que vrai vraiment je me demande ce
qu'ils comprennent
j'ai un document sur ma clé usb je veux
le mettre sur l'ordi d'accord d'abord
ouvre la fenêtre
ouais j'ouvre la fenêtre tu copies
le document je copie le document et
ensuite tu le col je le colle sur le
bureau et voilà merci cyprien lol à ta
mère tu dis lol berges j'ai un petit
message à toutes les personnes âgées qui
regarde cette vidéo
arrêtez tout de suite de manière
immédiate le jeu de mots face de bouc
on arrête s'il vous plaît vous n'avez
jamais remarqué qu'à chaque fois qu'on
fait ce jeu de mots les jeunes rigole de
cette manière alors on va sur face de
bouc
à
alors parfois ils pensent avoir
découvert des trucs par eux mêmes à y
avait quelques jours mon père pensait
avoir découvert rowsell avoir fait une
découverte pour moi du coup je me dis ah
c'est un bon jeu c'est sympa sachant que
ça fait un an que tous les jeunes n'y
joue déjà plus comme si les vieux
attendait un an ou deux avant de
pratiquer la technologie russell ouh là
là où la laisse moi un an ou deux et
peut-être je vais y jouer
je suis pas sûr après les plus à
plaindre ça ça reste les grands parents
moi mon grand père ça fait deux ans
qu'il a un téléphone portable à chaque
fois kingson on a l'impression qu'ils
redécouvrent l'objet
quelle est cette chose
ce qu'est ce qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
c'est
sans oublier qu'à chaque fois qu'il sort
il laisse son téléphone portable à la
maison
pourquoi 1 2 il faudrait que je explique
peut-être le mot portable dans téléphone
portable ça veut dire que tu peux le
porter c'est ou enfin bref pour résumer
je pense que les vieux voit les jeunes
de cette manière tu peut m'enlever le
mode avion s'il te plaît oui mais le
problème c'est très simple voilà merci
allez à bientôt téléportation
ah oui avant de se quitter
partager cette vidéo téléportation